let's take some calls from people in the
audience we do this via discord at
davidpakman.com
discord as a reminder if you are in the
discord waiting to talk to me your
nickname should be your name and where
you're calling from anything else
including name only or nicknames or
usernames
you are unfortunately going to get
skipped over the requirement for the
format is name and where you're calling
from in some order in some order like
for example
jay
from new jersey let's go first to jay
from new jersey jay welcome
hey david
my question is yes
how do you justify eating meat dairy and
eggs
who do i have to justify it to
well
when there's a victim involved
wouldn't you have to justify it to them
i i don't know
do is that if you perceive that there
are victims every victim gets an
explanation i don't even know what
you're saying
well yeah so like if you if someone if
you or someone decides to eat meat area
eggs yeah and if animals are dying for
that decision
yeah that's being made over and over
again do you feel like
you could justify
making that decision
be
to that victim who has to
suffer and die for it
like for example when i have my
cappuccino
could i go to a cow and say
tell the cow why i'm drinking their milk
for example
yeah like that cow who
had to
endure multiple pregnancies and then be
separated from their child and then of
course if the child is a male
um the males in the dairy industry
almost always well they always get
separated on the first day of life
and often they're killed on the first or
second day of life then
this process will happen over and over
again to the mother cows like
several times until they can no longer
produce milk any longer
and then they'll ultimately get sent to
the slaughterhouse
so yeah like in that this in scenario
you're painting like with the cappuccino
do you think that there is a like a
moral justification for
consuming animal products if it's not a
necessity if we could just
be using plant-based alternatives
instead
so the problem i have with this entire
framing is that it's so absolutist and
narrow and it's not really like the way
the world actually works so for example
sometimes you follow these things to
their logical conclusion like i've read
a lot about this and hopefully you'll
indulge me for a moment
if we say okay eliminate all animal
products whatsoever
great
so that now puts an incredible
incredible strain on a handful of crops
which now need to be grown in
dramatically larger quantities in order
to replace all of those animal products
this creates absolutely massive
monoculture farms which are absolutely
terrible for the environment
many of these monocultures require
absolutely bonkers amounts of water in
order to generate equivalent amounts of
for example protein the water use also
leads to many many animals dying
everything from
mice to you know all sorts of other
things and so
we can do the entire thing that i gather
is what you would consider to be morally
right
and then we would still end up killing
so many animals by virtue of how we
restructure and reorganize what humans
eat
are we really better off by killing
different animals through drought and
monoculture etc i mean i don't know you
tell me
oh how do you justify it to them
i would be interested in responding to
that counterpoint that you brought up
but
you you did kind of
not answer the question i asked the
answer to my question is i don't know
what i would tell a cow i've never
spoken to a cow so i i don't know but
what i'm telling you is it's the type of
question that's really just a black hole
it doesn't really go anywhere in terms
of answering the broader questions about
how would we feed the planet on five
monoculture crops that would have to be
exploded you know a million percent in
order to replace all the animal products
you're not answering that question to me
which is okay too okay what i'm telling
you is your framing is arbitrarily
narrow and sort of myopic
well i i can't respond to that to that
counterpoint that you bring up okay but
i do want to say that you know about the
meat dairy and egg industry like
it is
like terribly terribly cruel the
standard practices
of meat dairy and eggs so yeah i'm with
you right there i'm with you right there
the standard practices are horrible
what i do is okay you know i eat very
little red meat for example and when i
do i try to know exactly what farm is it
coming from where i could drive and see
what are the conditions i
you know i think that like for example
the
um
you know i'm on pasture free stuff where
i know exactly where it's coming you
know i'm i'm doing certain things for
myself but i agree with you the standard
practices are terrible you and me you
and i are on the same page
okay cool
yeah and then just to touch on like the
the resource intensive uh subject that
you brought up yeah
so
actually when you really look into the
amount of resources required that it
takes to
produce like
raise livestock and
breed these animals and then raise them
to slaughter weight
for meat and then also for dairy and
eggs
when you look at how much water and
crops and resources are needed for all
these different kind of animal products
yes it is just like
unbelievably
intensive on the environment and you're
absolutely right you're absolutely right
like if you've ever seen cowspiracy like
they they that's a documentary freedom
yeah i'm familiar with it conspiracy
and conspiracy is fine but it's also
just lacking a lot of context and
information
you what you also have to consider is if
we replace
all of those products
what are they replaced with to meet
certain caloric needs it ends up being a
very small number of things that can do
it which generates mono cultures that's
very bad for the environment in new and
other ways
jay i gotta run i've given you almost
ten minutes i know we're not gonna agree
there's one more i just want to say like
okay about the
amount of crops like it's always less
crops to eat a plant-based diet that's
first of all so if you want to talk
about crop dust there'll always be less
crop related deaths on a plant-based
plant-based diet but you still haven't
answered the questions how do you
justify
eating meat dairy and eggs when there is
a victim involved and you said
that i'd have to think about how i
talked to the cow jay i'd have to i told
you i think that those questions are
filled up i want to talk on the cow's
behalf the cows are dying for their
decision to put them no i've given you
more time than i give anybody i gotta
let you go okay
all right well think about it david
thank you all right
thank you boy see this is why i tend
when i saw the user was jay vegan i
almost got away from it
but um
[Music]
i do regret that
i do regret that
as many of you know i'm a busy person i
don't always have the exact correct
nutritional plan for my meals every
single day and that's why i also take a
multivitamin and a couple of supplements
but doing them all separately can be a
little bit time consuming which is why
athletic greens is just fantastic and
they're one of our sponsors i've been
using the athletic greens since last
year it just really simplifies nutrition
i just do a scoop of the ag-1 and i'm
getting 75 high-quality vitamins and
minerals and my probiotics and it's all
from whole food sources i drink it in
the morning i know i'm good i don't have
to be messing around with different
pills and supplements or whatever or
spend time planning when what time of
day do i need to take each one i just
get it all with one scoop you can put it
in a smoothie you can drink it straight
it tastes great and then i'm just good
for the day
it supports gut health and i'm getting
everything that i need and i'm looking
for athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d plus five free travel packs
when you go to athleticgreens.com
pacman and the link is down below